oh okay I got it I got it I got it I got
it party for so long good morning Hank
you're in the hotel room right next to
me so I should probably just say good
morning nerdfighters and welcome to a
day in our life on tour first the iPhone
alarm clock goes off at some ungodly
hour in the morning then I brushed my
teeth while trying to answer questions
about my hair such as how did that
happen then I meet up with Hank in the
Katherine in the hallway good morning
mr. oh yeah
cheater time library elevator the mouse
is hungry for knowledge time to load up
the minivan and then we drive while our
friend Ellen tells us how to get where
we're going
Oh Oh traffic you're so fun to get stuck
in sometimes I strained to appreciate
natural beauty while cars drive past
look natural beauty stupid truck stupid
crane I'm trying to appreciate natural
beauty then I live broadcast myself on
blogtv calm while inside the minivan due
to Hanks miraculous contraption hello me
how are you doing I can see my eyes in
my eyes and then we'll just be having a
perfectly polite conversation in
Katherine we'll be like have you guys
ever wondered about cows she's so good
at cows
out of nowhere you got to be ready
and finally we arrived in Pittsburgh
whereupon I begin to contemplate how I
will pone Maureen Johnson hi Maureen why
are we mortal enemies because everywhere
you go John you cross my name out of
lettuce no and designer clothes can we
just um like have a truce what would be
good I'm sure that there are some all
right
[Applause]
we really wouldn't worry I mean we did
for five weeks and examinations
I
funny girls
then late at night we get to a hotel I
go to bed and then I wake up early the
next morning and do it all again it
would be tiring if nerdfighters weren't
too incredibly awesome and also if I
didn't keep getting amazing shirts like
this Culver Creek t-shirt complete with
a swan nerdfighters I look forward to
seeing many of you in Kansas City and
st. Paul Hank I'll see you in the
morning
[Music]